Joanne not her real name gave evidence
to the inquiry she was abused as a
teenager by a chaplain in the
Benedictine Church and says she told
senior members of the clergy who did
nothing how did you feel I know it must
have been a mix of emotions but shame
fear isolation confusion pain
Suicidal Thoughts what devastated me is
decades later I had been to a Headmaster
I'd been to the Abbot and nothing was
done
and one by one they lied the government
will establish an independent inquiry
panel of experts the then Home Secretary
Theresa May launched the inquiry eight
years ago into institutional cover-ups
of abuse it had a bad start three chairs
resigned amid accusations of
establishment connections but the
inquiry did at times strike at the heart
of power did you have any suspicions
about him at all former liberal leader
David Steele admitted failing to pass on
allegations against MP Cyril Smith and
subsequently resigned from the Lords
even MI5 was implicated for not pursuing
allegations against a Tory MP who worked
for Margaret Thatcher I believed of
service
took a very narrow View and didn't
pursue that I swear by almighty God and
archbishops from the Catholic and
Anglican Church were told their
institutions turned a blind eye to
Decades of abuse there are shocking
stories of abuse and failures on the 458
pages of this report and what the
victims want who told those stories most
of all is for mandatory reporting to be
implemented that is if someone suspects
child abuse that they are obliged by law
to report it to the police
in its final report the inquiry
delivered three Central recommendations
the much wanted mandatory reporting a
child protection authority to oversee
institutions and the creation of a
financial redress scheme what is your
message to the new prime minister when
they pick up this report what's the key
thing they need to do the commitment we
want from them is to make the welfare of
children in this respect of child sexual
abuse and indeed others they may wish to
include an absolute priority the
Catholic and Anglican churches have
apologized for their failings but the
proposed conditions for mandatory
reporting are limited to things such as
someone actually confessing to abuse or
being abused it's uh proposing criminal
offenses in relation to a very narrow
set of situations but the vast majority
of the situations that the inquiry
actually saw in evidence where there was
a failure to report would not be subject
to that criminal penalty and that's our
concern survivors like Joanne relived
their past to safeguard Children of the
future it's up to the government now to
ensure that that courage is rewarded
Jason Farrell Sky News